c'est la question la question
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
autre petite nouveauté aujourd'hui celui
qu'elle peut éloigner de la réponse
devra mettre à déguisements de potes
pendant la deuxième partie de faire
vendre ma trace qui perd ma pote et il
le met directement sera pas la question
sus aux françaises pouvaient un fantasme
je le paie le verdict a pas d'amour avec
des hommes en uniforme à casal 10 58%
benhaim 70 jean michel mr 97 76 pour
maxime 30 pour kelly 73 55 pour isabelle
morini-bosc 73 pour christophe carrière
81 pour 18 mois m 65 pour géraldine
maillet 62 pour raymond benhaim c'est
votre cas vous faites partie c'est ben
euh c'est pas mal ça cardy au programme
à savoir l'uniforme c'est sexy eva vous
dirai pourquoi pas vous l'avez déjà fait
ou non mais d'uniformes et d'un mec de
chez midas
il n'est de faire une vidange son côté
rester sexy c'est viril oui pourquoi pas
pas vraiment kelly non moi ça me dit pas
trop salata l'uniforme de médecins
j'aime bien mon projet me dis bien
acheté pour guy lorsque jimmy s'était
passé et parce que c'est ça protège sa
soigneusement de la personne fort les
médecins que moi mon père il a pas de 12
ans par exemple
alors il est comme ça et quand le
thermomètre quoi bon c'est ce que vous
allez faire comme celle où le plan
devait chuter à vous déguiser en père
gad elmaleh voulu ni fort oui il faut un
uniforme les pompiers ataman l'uniforme
il fort parce qu'il ya un côté puissant
viril à elles sont pas peur un gm est
alors de vie les pompiers arrivent donc
c'est bien c'est la ctaq badaboum et de
quitter dans ça vous m'écoutez m'ont
fait du bien c'est bon là une forme où
il avait complètement complètement pas
comment j'adore le clairement militaires
allaient voter
le problème c'est que généralement ils
l'enlèvent chekwa ballet des formes ah
oui uniforme ou encore quand marie s'est
déjà déguisé l'umami excusez moi oui je
suis une [ __ ] on m'a mis ses de son mari
s'est déjà déguisé
patrick marie c'est tout ce passe comme
si ces infos oui d'accord ah oui et vous
est-ce que vous avez déjà ses labours en
blues vous êtes médecin urgentiste donc
idéal qu'il y avait raison souvent les
femmes / tu as ton les urgentistes et
pas trop sur les généralistes avec le
médecin de famille à voile à la papa
s'intéressent pas grand monde par contre
le médecin à l'hôpital celui qui sauve
des vies
il ya un côté un peu plus urgent est
plus sympa ouais on est dans l'urgence
et failli faire des études de médecine
bon oui c'était pas la spécialité d'une
écologie les rumeurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
photo mj tu vois tu vois je suis en
uniforme de battre ferrari fait vraie
vie la famille omarienne uniforme mois
deux militaires bah oui mais faire vous
êtes toujours un gars n'a pas d'état il
était très beau et malraux était en plan
et une sphère uniforme de la marine
américaine très très beau ouais on
rapporté péter martland y croire c'est
juste parce qu'ils aient des sous marins
et de peuf vol
oui et vous par exemple l'infirmière où
l'hôtesse de l'air ça vous fait
fantasmer mois ben oui voilà vous parle
alors arrêtez avec moi rien de monsieur
vous êtes un homme non non je ne suis
pas un homme
voilà je vous le dis aujourd'hui je vis
ma vie comme je l'entends et je rappelle
que je ne suis pas là dedans je suis
comme votre papa voilà donc les on parle
pas de ça voilà voulez parler de
confiture je voulais parler de 4 car
vous voulez parler de beaucoup tout on y
va mais pas de ça beinheim sinon vous
vous avez déjà fait l'amour d'une femme
[Rires]
jamais jamais il avait levé jamais en
uniforme non eva géraldine tu sûr que
oui moi en uniforme ou la personne et il
ya eu un délire vous avez déjà fin des
liens ou des soirées déguisées oui mais
après comme toi on d'un moment c'est
quoi ce soir sinon allez y avec spider
man le vélo bail ni personne buteur